in five four three two one
hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
just shooting podcast
back-to-back-to-back today we're gonna
do something really interesting because
I think there's a lot of people out
there that want advice on [ __ ] and they
don't really know who to go to because I
think growing up to like for me if I
wanted advice I always had like a group
of friends to go to okay but not
everybody has that [ __ ] right I think
that's why the Internet
helps out a lot of people people look
for advice and there's a lot of people
who say that watching like certain
videos like JK news and even my video oh
yeah they're like you know you guys
helped me grow up into the person that I
am today
yeah you must be a but um yeah there's
just some people out there who don't
really have a strong group around them
and so I think advice is really hard to
come by sometimes so I know for me
growing up I always had Michael my close
group of friends right and even now the
person that actually go to the most for
advices as my mom really she's a wise
ass [ __ ] [ __ ] dude she's [ __ ]
wise as [ __ ] she's crazy but she's
really wise so even whenever I went
through issues with uh with Mariel I
would call my mom and say yo what should
I do with this it's really like they're
growing up where you just this happened
like maybe over years no I didn't talk
to my mom at all man growing up it was
it was weird because I had this moment
with my parents we're not my parents my
mom she used to call me all the time
ignore that call I won't [ __ ] talk to
her hmm
in college she had a rule she goes well
now that you're off in college and
you're away from home the only thing
that I ask of you is that on Friday you
give me a call and then you let me know
what's going on that's it just give me a
recap
just to recap yeah I would not do it I
always I would forget it all the time so
she would just call me cursing me out
she could you stupid son of a [ __ ] oh
oh my mom curses up a storm oh he's like
you [ __ ] like you act like you
didn't grow up with anybody in your life
she goes whenever you come back home
don't even think about coming back your
[ __ ] dad today I screaming [ __ ] like
that that's nothing that she has told me
to kill myself she has done plenty of
room that's that's mom that's Korean
career I was gonna say that that's in
Korean I feel like things in Korean are
they're very harsh but the meaning is
less
right so there's like a famous like a
typical saying in Korean when you're
angry is Google or like but what seems
like you want to [ __ ] die yeah so she
said that to me all the time and all the
[ __ ] time she was hooking duck yes I
want to die it's like you who talks to
the kids like this yeah but she would
get mad at me all the time and I
remembered this one time where I was I
was in LA I was just driving around and
it was when I had my Camry and my [ __ ]
wasn't working like my radio wasn't
working so I didn't have anything else
to do so I was like [ __ ] it I'll call my
mom put on my little earbud I was like
hey what's up and then she just she was
like oh well look who decided to call
suddenly right mr. [ __ ] big shot me
all this attitude and then we just
started chopping it up and then
afterwards I got off the phone I reached
my destination my dad I talked to my dad
a week or so later and he goes do your
mom was in the best mood when you called
her oh she just wants to talk I didn't
know that she was calling me because she
wanted to nag me about yeah but she just
wanted a conversation with her son right
because she was just bored oh yeah I
know I've had those moments bro cuz yeah
since I moved out here my brother and my
dad my mom my mom she calls me probably
like every every now and then it's not
really that big but when my mom my
brother and my dad
they call me almost every day and it got
to the point where I was just like I
would see their calling like yeah hello
yep now cool yeah same [ __ ] yes I mean
like you know but but it took me to you
know realize like you know they you know
that like my brother we're like we're
like best friends yeah I mean he told me
growing up but like we that's just how
we were like Marlon Luigi like it was
like so when I moved out here I can tell
that he really just calls me just
because he wants to hear from his
brother yeah I know saying what your mom
is like I just want to see how my
brothers do it yeah you know and so I
being in LA always on the go you know
how it is bro you just move you got all
these different worries stresses and all
these dealing with stuff and in this
business that you forget to give them a
call yeah you know and when they call
you you're like yeah no it's cool it's
almost but it's almost like you're all
your frustrations gone on that phone
call like
I'm cool yeah yeah no I still haven't
got I haven't heard it's an audition
that you don't hear like if you don't
make it then they don't call they don't
call you to say you don't make it yeah
find out in the movie when you see it
yeah in that [ __ ] you know so they
don't understand the world that we're
coming from so they ask a lot of
questions it's not a curiosity but
sometimes it just gets annoying yeah and
then we had to kind of manage our
emotions because sometimes I feel that I
get irritated that stuff that they asked
that if somebody else asked I wouldn't
be so irritated oh I hate that I do that
yeah I hate that I do that uh who Esther
Perel is mm-hmm
okay Esther Esther Perel bro she is a
relationship coach and therapist right
yeah and she's from I think well she
knows like seven different languages
she's from like the Europeans like
Europe out there I thought what was it I
think it's like actually like Russia or
something I don't know but um she's
really she has two famous TED talks and
they talked about like one of them was
like infidelity and another one was like
viewing the relationship differently and
stuff like that but she was talking
about how to talk to your spouse or your
loved one the same way you would talk to
your coworker yeah the same way when you
come when you coat not not like a
co-worker that you hate but like the
same way no no no no not that co-worker
the same way you talked to a customer
yeah same we talk to a customer you're
like hey how you doing how's your day is
everything going well this whole thing
yeah
when you come home you're like she's
like oh how did a big like I was cool
yeah yep he's very short you just like
then I'm like oh I do that all the time
I say things too I respond to my girl
way differently than I would respond to
my homie yeah I know for sure and
there's other factors to that too
because it would be easy just to break
it down like that but it's because
number one you're around that person all
the time so it seems repetitive and
cyclical right so mind you if I was
around whatever your homie 24 [ __ ]
seven probably be the same [ __ ] way
it's not so much that that person that
you're with your your tree in that way
because oh I I'm kind of taking them
program which it might be a little bit
of that but it's just you just like
you're telling the same story over and
over again to the same person so you
don't feel like it needs to be said like
you know with my lady when I'm hanging
out and let's say I come back
and she says she goes how was your day
that's the last thing I want to talk
about because I just had to deal with it
even on the customer service aspect
right let's say you're working in
customer service and she says why can't
you talk to me like when you talk to
these customers when they come in you
ask them how their day is because I
don't give a [ __ ] about them
oh you're actually not even I don't even
care about your answer I'm an auto pilot
exactly I'm not actually wondering how
you doing today good and you know they
start talking you're like yeah so tell
me yeah I'm not interested in their [ __ ]
yeah you know with you I just like for
me how I explained it to where is that
when I come home or if I'm having a long
day and you come home and you come at me
with all this energy yeah I just need
like 30 minutes to reset and then I
could be interested in what you're
saying man yeah that's my girl bro I I'm
not gonna lie I'm the other side of it
where I'm thinking you know what you
know what it is it makes it even worse
is because when she comes home she has
his dog that's like super huge and it's
like her child yeah so she sees she's
like hey hey oh my god he handsome like
telling the dog and she's used to hey
babe and I'm like yo what's up and then
I feel dumb because I can't say I'm
jealous of this dog yeah like the energy
that you're giving the dog why can't I
get that it feels like a dumb argument
but it's like I'm it's it's somewhat
valid because it's like what's the
energy that you're giving the dog should
not give it me
and then what how can we fix that or
what needs to happen because I also like
I like I like being acknowledged when
you come home like you know not just
like walk straight pass and you gotta go
to the room and under but you're like
you're saying it makes sense you're
somewhat resetting yeah but it's just
it's just a small thing of like hey babe
and then you can still do whatever you
got to do yeah you know I mean I I would
get mad when she would just walk in wool
first well she should say hi at least
well yeah yeah I'll be nice yeah yeah
yeah but also like coming in the on the
phone coming in the house on the phone
that's a pet peeve of mine yeah coming
in on the phone and I also tried it
because I you know it happens you know
cuz I'm not it's weird when you stay
outside on the phone because it's like
who the [ __ ] talk to like they can't
talk to the house
that's a little weird yeah but like when
you're going to the house that should be
your your your way of getting off the
phone of like oh I just got home so
thing you stay on the phone now you're
just like okay or like you just feel
like a piece of furniture yeah ain't
like cuz they're just still on the phone
and they're walking around and say and I
get it if it's like a very deep
conversation you're with your darn phone
with your mom or something like that but
I don't know this is a pet peeve of mine
yeah I mean everybody's different how do
you know about that you and I are
opposites right so she comes home and
I'm laying down and I'm still working on
some stuff she comes in she goes hey
Baba let me tell you about my day I'm
just like shut the [ __ ] up but because I
just need time to switch modes cousin
I'm still even though I'm it at the
house I'm still working yeah so when she
comes in she's actually coming in
disturbing my work so I need to give me
30 minutes so I'm like oh I gotta be
fiance she's checked out she said what
she comes home she checked out she's
like everything's right you're still
injured so myself
yeah yeah yeah so I'm still you know me
by myself type of person so I just need
like 30 minutes for me to reset so I
could be the better boyfriend getting
boyfriend mode yeah so just I need that
little time yeah and so I'm pretty sure
for her when she comes and sees the dog
the dog can't talk right the dog is
always the same thing every time yeah
great sort of like like the dog hadn't
seen her in 4,000 well yeah he comes
running toward me with his tongue
hanging out not yeah so it's one of
those things where you know and dogs
don't talk back it's just she's just
getting what she needs from the dog and
that's about it yeah so with with human
interaction is different when you say
how you're doing there's actually a
conversation that happens after she's
done paying the dog the dog goes away so
it's a very one-sided relationship when
somebody opens up that door and they
come in and they go hey how was your day
what are you doing now she has to
interact and she has to be engaged and
she was just doing that at work the
whole [ __ ] time right so I'm pretty
sure if I don't know if you had this
conversation with her and I'm pretty
sure she just resets for like 20 minutes
gets her [ __ ] done relaxes gets in her
comfortable piece shows has to go pee
her bladder is completely full all day
apparently that's girls dude yeah yeah
she [ __ ] has to go go pee it's just a
change out of her out of her scrubs
changes
and then you know then it's like okay we
do want to eat yeah yeah and I'm just
like and then I'm the dick where I'm
like well hello for you all day with
that's dope though because I think
Muriel would prefer that because it
makes her feel like she's wanted in mist
right cuz I'll be real
Jamis because it hasn't been that long
cuz I know that she's coming back like
she's missed if I travel mmm alright so
she goes and I don't know why it always
makes me feel weird when she goes are
you gonna miss me and in my mind I'm
like it's only two days mmm relax but
then I leave and then I'm in my hotel by
myself I'm like I guess I do miss her
yeah I just want her to give me that
opportunity to say it when I let me see
yes let me say it I don't like that
birthday I don't like the oh do you miss
me I'm like yes but like let me say let
me say it it seems forced yeah let me
say it you know I mean it becomes really
awkward for me like at that moment when
she said do you miss me yeah it seems
very insincere yeah right so how I would
equate it is sometimes when people
aren't ready to say I love you and then
you ask them do you love me it becomes
really awkward yeah yeah I feel it yeah
and it's not the moment for me to say it
right so for her when I leave and then
I'm chilling the hotel by myself a day
later I'm like hey I really miss you she
goes but you couldn't say it to me when
I asked you because you put me on the
spot right and then and then also I
don't know this is worse but if they
tell you that they take say hey I miss
you like that's alright that's the same
thing it's you now you're obligated to
say it back but what if I'm not ready to
miss you yet I'm still kind of good
he's my three letters ko oh that's cool
yeah yeah bro we had this thing to where
I told her I loved her in like the first
like few months that we were together
yeah me too and I was like I was like
boys yeah I told I was like I think I
could really fall in love with you is
what I said right and she wasn't ready
for that [ __ ] but I was pretty confident
you know lo and behold we're we're
engaged
yeah so for her I used to say I when
when we did start saying I love you to
each other I said it to her all the time
but she would never say it back she
maybe set it back a couple of times I
told you when you're comfortable with it
you're fine no-ho-ho
I put a ring on her she says I love you
all the time now yeah all the time
yeah and she goes you don't say I love
you like you used to back in the day
I'll say yes but you scarred me yeah I
said I love you for [ __ ] four years
straight you never said it back to me
you know I'm gonna say never you rarely
said it back to me hmm
and now I'm tired you emptied a clip
yeah and I love you I don't have anymore
yeah yeah there was no you didn't feel
mad you didn't fill up my [ __ ] [ __ ]
back up no Mike now when I say I love
you it's few and far between because you
conditioned me to not say it as much
because it made you feel uncomfortable
so now I'm working back saying I love
you more often because it became awkward
for me because I kept saying and I never
got it back yeah so I was trying to
explain to her that display that to her
and she's just like no no I guess I
won't say I love you anymore at all I'll
say that's not fair because you made
this condition happen I was fine saying
I love you all the time I'm a bit of
family we said I love you all the
[ __ ] time yeah yeah but now that you
didn't say it to me for like three or
four years like comfortably now I'm
conditioned to feel weird about it so
just give me some time and I'll work
back to it right I say I like saying it
randomly like I don't cuz you know you
have the time there's like Kurt of
course when you're leaving to work okay
I love you bye have a good day
yep or when you up you know before you
say goodnight I love you type of thing
but I'm I'm very like out of nowhere you
know sometimes I scream her babe she's
like well why I love you how long have
you guys been together
uh we've been together almost two years
now
living together almost two years now oh
yeah we're a long distance for like
eight months nine months long-distance
and that she moved in January of 2000
did your relationship get better or
worse from that from moving in at first
at moving in at first
oh it was oh it was a we were solid we
were solid and then it got bumpy due to
mistakes done them from me you know I
made some mistakes and what did you do
oh yeah I mean I mean yeah III slipped
up you know yeah I slipped up and you
know she was it was a it was a crazy
time you do do this you try em you cry
yeah Nazi and she was like very you know
of course hurt you know the mean but and
and for me this was something that
because I've always been honest with her
this was this is like my first
relationship where I've been completely
transparent this podcast is brought to
you by Skillshare my friends and I'm
telling you right now have you ever ever
wondered how you were going to learn
after your traditional education are
there things that you are curious about
in terms of developing a skill hobbies
entrepreneurial skills well let me tell
you something Skillshare has your back
because they offer hundreds and
thousands of courses to millions of
people that have taken up this offer
listen Skillshare for me has been
something that I have been enjoying a
lot I am somebody who is a serial
hobbyist on top of just being a stereo
hobbyist I don't just do things in a
very lackadaisical way I actually get
serious and I want to learn fundamental
basics before I even start anything when
it comes to photography videography or
any anything in those creative aspects
or all of the above that's what I enjoy
photography and videography is something
that I'm personally into and when I
first started getting into it I didn't
learn a lot of the fundamentals when it
came to looking at a camera or doing
things which is something that I really
regretted well Skillshare has a bunch of
courses for somebody like me that wants
to get into those hobbies and it's not
just that there's a bunch of different
courses that you guys can get into it's
probably the best thing that I've done
for myself so far in terms of pursuing
an education outside of traditional
education and I kind of like learning at
my own pace and that's what Skillshare
does for me so check this out join the
millions of students already learning on
Skillshare today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering genius brain
listeners two months of unlimited access
to thousands of classes for free to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash brain
again go to Skillshare comm slash brain
to start your two months now that's
Skillshare comm slash brain yeah in the
beginning I mean I'm talking my like
when we're a long distance I was like
hey I still am out here and
lay like a bee flirting or this isn't
that and and you know there was a
there's a level of respect that she had
because she was like okay you know
you're being honest I appreciate that
and she told me her truths and stuff
like that but that was like the deal
getting honest you know and I you know
went outside elationship and she was
completely hurt because like Oh cuz that
was a thing I tried hiding it
I tried hiding it and I went like three
months hiding it and there's a long time
bro yeah and I yeah I know I know and I
went and it was so like it was just
eating me up and what it was is that I
went to go to her brother's wedding
and she's one of the bride's bridesmaids
right they were called yeah and I'm
sitting here like oh my god family loves
me and I'm sitting like this is this is
she kills you on the inside
Oh bro it's [ __ ] it's it's it's
horrible it's horrible you know if
you're a decent human being if you are a
nice person you made a mistake this yeah
it's gonna eat you up yeah for sure
and so now came back home and I i sat
her down actually I actually told her
mom that this was I was gonna do this
when we got back because her mom was
like just tell her when you go home
don't tell her here here yeah cuz you
know she's having a good time of her
family's like that yeah go home bro and
I I you know sit it down and we talked
about it I opened up to her and I tell
her and you know she has that you know
when you're so pissed you have like a
laugh yeah she was like that's scary
dude yeah oh yeah
scary yeah terrifying man and she left
at first she was like she just left she
didn't tell me thing and she left and
then when she came back I got like a
round two feels like all the questions
and then that's when like the tears were
flow and that's when she was really like
crying and pissed could it goes from
shocked and then it sinks in and then
she starts to feel hurt mm-hmm and then
and then she goes to take a shower this
she comes back and I was around three
this is where stuff was getting thrown
of course I guess it goes to anger
yeah bro like oh my gosh so many
different motions and then this is the
the crazy part bro
in the middle of the night it's 3
o'clock in the morning and I'm like I
didn't even like I didn't sleep on the
bed rest up on the floor in the room but
I didn't sleep in the bed with her
and uh when she had got up in the middle
of the night to go use the restroom and
I was like I'm a getting a bit like I'm
just gonna get in the bed must be on the
far edge but I'm again so I got in the
bed and I'm sitting there and then she
got in bed and then I say about maybe
like 10 15 minutes go by she sits up and
she was like hey and I was like yes she
was like I forgive you
damn I was like and I'm and I'm I'm face
up like my I'm looking at the ceiling
and tears are just going down into my
ears but yeah I'm just like cause it's
such that's so gracious of her what yeah
you know she was just like we've gone
through so much and I've I've gone so
far to just let this dumb mistake just
ruin what we've you got a good one go
bro because I thought what you're gonna
say is that you were in bed and then
when you looked up there was a knife at
your throat nah man nah she hit me she
hit me with the dagger love damn dude
yeah bro that's [ __ ] crazy yeah and
she she said I forgive you and you know
you made a mistake and you know it's
worked this out you know and I you know
got back on it and you know what's cool
it still was rough because the trust is
gone yeah I got a built that [ __ ] back
up gotta build it up and then I you know
I have I you have you have I have my
mode of like you know okay I'm we're
gonna work through this we're worth it
and then that starts to fade through me
because now I'm like alright well I'm
not at the [ __ ] zoo animal yeah I
don't want to seem like I'm like in
prison right now
ya know I mean cuz it's levels to it now
she is she is completely you know valid
for her feelings right but it's like
there's a different like taking
advantage
and of light no you can't go out you're
not going in you know me yeah if it gets
really blurred yeah yeah and so that was
a very tough thing to work through
because there's there's the
communication bro to be able to say yo I
still have to go out and perform I will
come home when I'm done either you come
with me if you can't I just I gotta go
out you know this is what I you know
just thought those type of things so you
know we got through it man went and
worked through it and um you know we're
here that's [ __ ] crazy man I think
it's it's hard for people to wrap their
head around stories like this because I
think in our mind prior to anybody
getting cheated on mmm they say I'm
worth more than that so the moment
somebody cheats on me I'm gonna cut it
off and I'ma start afresh with somebody
who really believes that I'm worth yeah
that's the worst bro that's the worst
well also on both ends with what she
said that was for her perspective right
yeah on my perspective I feel so bad
that she doesn't have a pure guy anymore
yeah you don't I mean like now she's
dealing with somebody who has these
permanent scars
yeah and now she has permanent scars
right and so you also I you know I got I
got all you got you go all different
routes bro you get biblical and you get
spiritual you get all these things so
that cuz you need something for healing
yeah right so it's like now you know
yeah there's scars but now you have to
look at the scars as as a you know
something that you overcame yeah you
know what I mean well that's the thing
it's just um and I say that I was
probably on the side before more this
way words I go somebody let's say Muriel
cheats on me like a one-night stand
thing but I would drop her in a second
and I was and I say that in my mind now
but I think what people forget too is
that history there's a lot of history
that binds a relationship together
because when you you have this missed
moment in this fault that happened are
you willing to risk everything that you
built up to this point because
a single mistake yeah because is that
mistake definitive of this person's
character for the rest of their life or
is this just a mistake that they've made
this one time yeah if they're gonna
learn from and get better from yeah so
that's where that balance comes in
because before I always thought to
myself that if I get cheated on I I
would leave them [ __ ] immediately
yeah but now I'm thinking if I did not
did not to say that I'm trying to give
her an excuse to do something yeah but
it's more like I I don't know if it
would be that easy for me I don't think
so I think when I was younger yet or if
we were together for two three months
four months five months yeah yeah yeah
but yeah this is that's the same thing
because you know she's told me to like
what would you do you know and and I
told her I was like yeah I would
probably like I'd be the same I'd be
pissed
you know I would want to leave you know
I want to cut this off yeah especially
the male ego of yeah what you're gonna
you know Chito that you know I mean but
yeah like you said you don't know you
don't know how you're gonna react you
know it's weird because emotions and
memories have a lot to do with how you
behave in a relationship yeah because if
you've built so many things up it's sad
because there's that weird balance of
are you not leaving this person just
because you think it's a waste of your
time because you wasted X amount of
years and you don't want to start over
again or are you not leaving this person
because you truly love this person and
you feel like this is the person that
you're gonna be with for the rest of
your life yeah and that's where it
really gets muddled up you got to really
be strong in your individual choices at
the point yeah which I think a lot of
people struggle with a lot cuz I just I
just don't [ __ ] know so for example I
got uh I was with somebody who there's a
weird situation so number one there was
a girl that I was dating this is private
prior to Mariel this was like two years
before I met Muriel and she got it in
her head that I really liked this friend
of mine right that we were like either
doing some [ __ ] or some other stuff
number one I was more offended on the
fact that out of all the women that you
thought that I'd be messin wit was with
that one I was like disgusting it was
out of all the [ __ ] with that one
yeah right you know I was kind of it was
weird because we were all hanging out
and I
not with that girl and mind you I used
to flirt with that girl a lot like I'd
say four years ago but then I got to
know her and I was like [ __ ] whack
and that we moved on and we just stayed
friends yeah and even then as friends
that girl and I we hung up maybe once or
twice a year at most yeah until I got
sick of her
so she came around and then so she's
like oh I haven't seen you in a while
let's hang out and I was like cool well
my girlfriend's here - lets all hang out
together and she knows her so it was me
my brother her and my girlfriend it was
a group of four people and she was there
hmm and I guess you know she and I have
a joking relationship we clown each
other a lot and so that night my girl
phone was like yeah I'm not feeling too
well so I'm gonna go home I didn't
really think much of it I was like oh
cool what are you gonna do she goes I'm
not feeling too well I have to go hang
out with my mom or whatever yeah lo and
behold like a month later you know she's
you know she started feeling a little
weird and then we started talking about
hey what's going on like you're acting a
little funny she goes yeah I just have
something to tell you I'm like what's
going on she was you know like a month
ago when you were hanging out with we're
all hanging out together like I don't
think I really liked you hanging out
with her at all I was a hold on a second
and already I was like getting a little
nervous I was like number one that was
the first time I saw her in a year and
you were there right you know so what's
the problem
that's a weird thing and guess what
before we got together I asked her I was
like hey are you okay with me being
friends with her if not then I'll tell
her that we need to create space and
then and she'll be okay with it
because we're close but we're not that
close okay right and she goes no like I
love her it's great
she said that verbally she was feeling
certain ways about it without
communicating that and so I guess that
night what happened was she went home to
go on this this other dude like really
[ __ ] with her like really liked her a
lot
so she went on to go have dinner with
him instead that night and I was that oh
really that's what you did uh yeah I did
all the steps right just there I told
her about it everything and I was like
hold on so you got hurt so the reason
why you did that was specifically so you
could hurt me and I got so [ __ ] mad
not because of the fact that she was
trying to step out I mean it was more
because of how intentful how her intent
was to [ __ ] hurt me
she wanted to damage me yeah and I'm
like damn I would never in a million
years let's say if I cheated on you it
would never be so I could hurt you it
was because I made a [ __ ] drunken
mistake where I was just [ __ ] horny
or something yeah because then I could
base it on this animal instinct of
wanting to have sex then I would have
this like okay I get it
you know you weren't satisfied in a
certain era so you found something else
yeah but the difference is you did
something because you were trying to
[ __ ] stick a dagger in my heart and
so I got so [ __ ] and I remember - cuz
a couple my buddies were at my I said
this huge apartment on k-town and they
were using the spate to shoot space to
shoot a [ __ ] music video for the
YouTube and they just said they could
hear me screaming at the top of my
[ __ ] lungs in my cuz it happened
while they were shooting yeah and I just
heard banging because I kept [ __ ]
punching my fist into the [ __ ] door
over and over because I was so [ __ ]
mad yeah but I in that situation she and
I were together for less than a year it
wasn't worth it and I even tried to
rekindle it but it just died after that
point only because I felt like the
intent was was so malicious mm-hmm you
know what I mean yeah I think that's
where I kind of drew my life you believe
in like a rekindle or connection like
reconnecting type of thing like if a
connection that canikin kind of
connection be rekindled if a connection
is lost I think so I think people after
a while depending on what the situation
was why why the spark died it could have
been because you guys grew as separate
people maybe you guys grew into better
people and you guys meet each other
again it's like meeting a brand new
person III think that does happen a lot
where people they they look at each
other and they go oh [ __ ] you're better
than you were before and I'm also in a
better place mm-hm
sometimes - I feel I've seen people in
relationships where I truly believe that
just wrong place wrong time
mmm everything works you guys are great
together but you guys are not in the
right place you're emotionally unstable
you're still trying to figure yourself
out so when you guys meet each other
that tension makes you clash wrong place
wrong time and they meet somebody else
but sometimes I feel that if they met
two years after that they actually met
they probably would have stayed together
yeah yeah that's crazy that's crazy to
call that you know to even know
you know if so is this a bad time or
wrong time you know yeah this podcast is
brought to you by purple baby purp oh my
back feels great and I'm sleeping nice
because this is one of the best
mattresses out there are we talking
about a mattress that can I don't know
cuddle you to sleep
to make your back feel great to keep you
cool at night but not hot at the same
time are we talking about a mattress
that is firm and soft then we're talking
about a purple mattress man I have been
sleeping on this purple mattress now for
quite a few months and it has been the
best choice I have ever made in my life
because my back feels great my sleep is
fantastic and I know that the science
behind this is made by rocket scientists
yes we're talking about that material is
some rocket science material that is the
technology that goes behind this lovely
mattress and that is the reason why I
have been sleeping so so well now the
purple mattress will probably feel
different than anything you've
experienced because my friends the
unique material is amazing I can't say
enough I really can't
so you're going to love purple and now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to 84-88 the only way to get
this free pillow is the text brain to
eight four - eight eight eight
that's be are a I n two eight four eight
eight eight message and data rates may
apply because I know I know in my
relationship I get I get worried because
I come with a lot of baggage yeah you
know and we all come with baggage but
like I was told recently about you know
affirm her she was like you know a lot a
lot of what goes on with the
relationship it comes on like as me and
I'm not saying like petty arguments is
like you know the woman's situation you
know I mean and it's things that I've
been having - I've never self reflected
so much than with I was with her like
this this is the most I've ever
reflected on myself like of
you know the trauma that I've had when I
was younger or you know what why do I
love women this much or why am I so you
know not not just like a natural oh yeah
I'm a man that's what was what we like
to do it's just it's there's other
things from it like doesn't come from
insecurities or my past and all these
things and it's always that there's
always been stuff like that because even
even after that situation I mean yeah
there was there was a some other
slip-ups that she knows she knows about
and there was other things and she was
just like yo what's going on and this is
another is another situation where she
she also it proves that this girl's is
[ __ ] amazing
yeah because when I went to go I went to
go perform in Dallas and I'm just I'm
featuring and it was just a one-night
feature and man I mean I'm feeling like
I'm the [ __ ] like after I get off the
stage they're like we got a section for
you too you like and we know that this
club this is none and then like our
section is right next to the Cowboys
like quarterback like the quarterback is
their dak is there Ezekiel is there yeah
well we're right this woman though I'm
dancing and now you got a deck like
telling me like Oh bro keep that bro
like yeah you really he's offering me
drinks of [ __ ] and there's girls and
we're all dancing his bro I'm on like
cloud behind yeah yeah yeah right and
and then yeah I start flirting a little
too much to start just the distance nap
whatever right and so I get back home I
break over there oh [ __ ] because I felt
so guilty and then I'm like oh she don't
deserve this at all
yeah like I'm like like I got I got
really I got some [ __ ] that I gotta
[ __ ] take care of like this it's
ridiculous I'm tired of feeling like
[ __ ]
right yeah and so she obviously doesn't
know why the [ __ ] I broke over her right
cuz I didn't want to expose that to her
cuz she obviously forgave me already
right and and so she ends up like is
confused and all these things and couple
days go by we have two bedrooms so I'm
in my the other bedroom and she comes to
the room and she was just like I can't I
can't leave like she was like she was
telling me like I
I really don't know I want to be with
you I can't leave like what is what's
the problem yeah what's going on you
know what I mean and I told her I was
like I'm just tired of like hurting you
and at that point she was like what did
you do she's like she cleared it up yeah
I smell some [ __ ] wait I'm going on what
happened yeah and I was like I was doing
some extra [ __ ] up there in Dallas
yeah and if she was and that's what she
broke down again and then she but this
time she handled it differently it
wasn't like the first one yeah she
handled this one differently because she
was like she was like okay one do you
want to be with me let's get this out of
the way do you want to be with me let's
figure this [ __ ] out yeah be real do you
want to be with me I said yes she's like
why do you want to be with me and I told
her the reasons why why why I want to be
with you you know you make me feel great
I love how I am go around each other
I love for the person that you are you
make me better I root for you you root
for me like we're we're really like
partners out here you know I mean like
we're really like that that feels great
that I haven't had before you know I'm
like just let her know what it is she's
okay
so she's like what is it about when you
go to a different city than what it is
here because when you're here you're the
best boyfriend I could ask for
yeah I love you you're great right but
when you go to a different city this
[ __ ] happens right so she's like what is
it and and shields I don't give me no
[ __ ] buy your drugs she was like
tell me what's up and I'll just like
when I'm in a different city I feel like
I'm the [ __ ] I feel like I'm the actual
like entertainer that I'm supposed to be
when I'm in LA I'm a boyfriend I'm a
screen printer I'm a designer and I do
websites and then I'm a comedian yeah
whenever I get booked yeah you know and
so and so I was like I feel like I died
like when I when I get booked to it in a
different city I'm just in that city as
Christo so the comedian yeah you know
and this and that's and that's what
makes me feel like this is what I was
supposed to
doing when I'm back home it's like this
is just [ __ ] you know and I'm not not
saying that our relationship is [ __ ] I'm
saying this isn't what I'm out here like
like this is what I was rolling as she
goes she goes well why don't we work on
you being the [ __ ] and where you live so
that when you go to a diverse city you
don't feel like you're better you're
just the same Chris yeah and I'm like
god dammit what's your ring size how do
you come up with this yeah she was like
she broke me down saw all the [ __ ] you
know and of course I had to be
completely honest of like telling her no
this is what's going on with me like I'm
not trying to [ __ ] you I'm not even
trying to win you back because I always
I broke up with you because I know that
you deserve better
I guess you know this whole thing and
she broke me down and she'll just like
won't work on that and then once I know
how man you don't deserve her bro
everybody's like damn who is this woman
Oh bro Oh bro first of all first of all
this is the first platform ever talk
about this oh wow yeah I mean I got to
tell you this dope so I really tried I'm
really trying to make sure it is very uh
serious light not necessary it's what
I'm saying like yeah I don't know I
don't want her to be like eat up she
don't have power she can't he know she
does that's the misconception here she's
somebody who knows what she wants and
the great thing is is that she knows how
to communicate really [ __ ] well yeah
and the fact that she's invested into
you not because it doesn't seem like
she's invested you just because at the
time I think she could really really
knows who you are as a person
Yeah right and she understands that
humans are flawed and her choices to
stay with this person that she really
loves who is it who in her mind and
heart she knows is a good person
yeah and I think the communication that
you guys have is great as at this point
more on her side right because I think
for you you're having issues of number
one guilt because you do glover you know
it's it's a weird space to be in right
it's because you're making these actions
thinking that you're doing something
great for her yeah right and for her it
doesn't work out that way he's like no I
what I want is us for us to be committed
and for you to be open and communicate
this to me for you to just bounce is
actually opposite of what I feel like I
deserve yeah because in your mind you're
thinking you're doing something great
for her when it really had turned to
something for yourself because it's
eating you up inside
yeah and that's where it becomes really
confusing right it's like oh I think I'm
doing this for her he's doing this for I
don't wanna feel guilty anymore so here
you go
exactly yeah it almost seems selfish but
at the same time it is very selfish and
so for her I think the great thing about
her is that she she really knows how to
just talk to you yeah right and that's
the hard part yeah I think what most
people don't realize is that they think
that monogamous relationships are the
easiest thing to do right yeah it's
actually in my personal opinion it's the
harder route because it's easier just to
live freely without staying into a
single commitment yeah most people can't
even commit themselves to a single
[ __ ] career or a job or a thought
what makes you think that you could
commit yourself to one person for the
rest of your life yeah I think when you
package things right and you prepare
yourself for that you have to realize
everything that that entails yeah for me
I like monogamous relationships and this
is what I have in my head the reason why
I like monogamous relationships and
having one person there for me is
because there's something that I get
from something like your situation
there's no way that you would [ __ ]
around with the girl and she they would
understand how you're saying how you're
feeling and what you want out of life
and just [ __ ] around with you no
[ __ ] way yeah you have to take time
and develop that stuff yeah for me
that's what I enjoy I enjoy the fact
that I had this person next to me that
understands me I don't have to
constantly explain myself I don't have
to dress the best all the time I don't
have to look a certain way I not the
smell a certain way just to harbor your
attention yeah she's just there and she
loves me for who I am that's the beauty
of a monogamous relationship right the
other side of that is that I think
naturally we want to be able to do the
things that we want without the weight
on our shoulders but then for me it's a
give-and-take it's like what are you
what do you find precious in your life
is are these glimpses are these moments
of you going on she's used the words
glimpse yeah she's use that yeah
whatever what are these moments are
these do you are you are you are you
living for these moments or
these things are just little diesel
yeah yeah and I went with that one what
that what what though
but um yeah man and and I guess it's
easier for me to talk about now because
she did make her first little joke yeah
you know she did her first little jab
yeah I don't know maybe like a couple
months ago you know what's funny is that
I added on to the joke it was like okay
we're not that good yeah man she's bro
she's a solid girl and this was
something that uh even kept a Kevin it
on they wanted to talk about on the love
hour about how we're working through
this you know I mean and I've talked to
my girl about it and she she was like
honestly it's a row even more thinking
above me she was like this she was like
honestly it's all up to you on how you
feel people are gonna vu if you're cool
with like any type of judgments then
just like I mean I don't mind talking
about it we can we could do it I like
this though because it's the reason why
I like this so much is because there's a
lot of people out there that have done
what you've done but they're so good at
lying about it bro that's what I'm
saying I'm like why can't I be like
y'all say I don't wanna do this anymore
I'm saying I'm saying I'm talking about
like bro I'm faced I've tried to yeah
like cuz yo my homies I can get away we
detour this person gets away with it and
when I tried to live that life bro with
like this this is how I know I'm a
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] cheater like I'm a
little [ __ ] yeah because every time
I've told it like one of the homies are
like bro what the why the [ __ ] did you
tell her yeah they're like tripping out
they didn't like even my dad was like oh
you're more of a man than I am son yeah
like what you told her and I'm like yeah
because he's like this she did she find
out of it no I told her like I told her
the truth like yeah that's that's that
was my that was that's the thing like I
grew up like that like my mom she could
get anything out of me as long as she
says Papa Dios is listening which means
God is listening yeah I get I'll get it
out yeah give me a little white lie she
black populace listening I'm like Oh
fine I didn't do the homework like I'll
just know whatever so I've always been
like that
and so yeah I tried living a lifestyle
of like you know oh I don't know they
don't have to know I like that I like
that though that's how I am that's why
Muriel knows - no matter where I go you
steppin on nobody you know I mean I
might I might get a little flirtatious
but that's as far as it goes yeah like I
said we talked about this earlier the
sin is in the ball side you jack off in
a hotel your mind is clear done
[ __ ] yeah you you I'll [ __ ]
solve cancer right now that I jack up
did you tell me what the [ __ ] it is
there's some type of equation that says
yo scientists have not been able to
figure out how to cure cancer and it's
on this piece of paper
maybe the jackoff I'll solve that in two
seconds that's not clear my money's my
sin isn't my ballsack
yeah that's nothing yeah no and that was
one thing that I had to be like more
practical about because I was like I
tried cutting every leg bro when I tell
you when I tried cutting everything off
I was like babe I'm not gonna look at
any girl I'm gonna unfollow every girl
that I follow I'm not gonna jack off I
got like I was straight up like it my
life is committed to you Yeah right
she's not realistic oh it's not that
she's not realistic at all like I like
cuz I remember like I had jacked off and
I was like [ __ ] like [ __ ] I cheated a
geylang I feel like I cheated like I was
so hard on myself yeah I mean no pun
intended but yeah I was like no hard of
myself alright so she tried shaking jack
jacking off away from me and I'm like
alright babe look okay I got a jack I
got jack off okay
I may look at porn every now and then I
had nothing to do with you they look
better than you everything's bigger or
better without no I'm just I mean it's
hard even it's hard to just [ __ ] to
even explain porn it's just it's [ __ ]
I think I think as long as you can see
porn for me to starts to become
problematic when people can't separate
reality from fantasy
that's where porn starts to become a big
issue where people start masturbating so
much to porn that they can't even have
sex with their partners anymore oh yeah
because they live in this weird fantasy
in this alcohol exactly that's what I'm
saying like maybe I'm getting my first
note out so when my girl gets home she
probably get this she bought to get this
second round empty dick and she don't
think it's much she don't think it's the
first round so she goes in my first
round is it's actually my second round
but I'm [ __ ] for help what I always
tell guys
you know I can't last night that's why
you're supposed to jack off first like
an hour rest don't want to come in
you're good to go
oh yeah a little longer and the nuts
kind of rope it's like replenished a
little bit you kind of [ __ ] stuck the
Ambo back in yeah so I mean that's that
weird part like we're we're porn oh I
know some guys who had like that porn
issue before and when it starts to mess
with their reality that's when it's a
problem and I think that's what happens
when you you know you have these
glimpses and these moments you're living
in that moment of yo this girl's [ __ ]
fine we're having a great time but when
you look at the bigger scope of things
is like okay yeah what you had with that
person when you made that mistake you
could literally have with anybody but
what you have with the woman that you
have right now you can't have that with
somebody else right and so my mind
though even if it's a risk to me which
is not much of a risk there's no there's
no reward like this what's the [ __ ]
reward of this yeah and you feel like
[ __ ] right when you nut even after
jacking off oh you're like I'm a [ __ ]
pig what am i doing you look around
you're setting like what is this that's
when you jack off the weird [ __ ] you're
like what was I think what was a weird
video done you sensed a little same [ __ ]
with you no because I yo listeners if
you're [ __ ] around don't because it's
it's not worth it I promise you isn't
any weight ain't worth it yeah I think
the hard part is is like if you're if
you're if you had this thought when you
get into a long-term relationship
understand what a long-term monogamous
relationship entails yeah if you're not
ready for that don't commit yourself to
it yeah just don't do it and also here's
here's the the also the fucked-up part
okay I don't know how the other way to
say it but in the beginning of our
relationship because we were so honest
there was a lot that was accepted oh
yeah yeah yes
and the and that there was luck and so
this was something that she admitted as
well yeah so this isn't a a a point the
finger like well hey what about her this
is something that she's also told me
like I'll admit like the way we started
it it really put a platform of a
foundation of it was very conducive to
the type of behavior that you were
exhibiting yeah
yeah so so there was so there was things
where we kind of like played around or
like we would like you know she would
send me a picture of a girl and be like
oh my god what do you think about this
one like so there were there was things
where like it was just it got so crazy
that this is the type of relationship we
are to where I got [ __ ] wild I did
like I got way out of what it actually
was you know yeah you know I still got
out of the line even even though
everything was [ __ ] in my favor you
know I mean and she still tells me to
say she's like you [ __ ] it up but it's
like but it's like that that was
something that I appreciate like I I'm
glad that she did bring up cuz she was
like I give you that you know yeah we we
started off like this like we were like
this wild-ass spontaneous couple that we
were like this is hey how we are yeah
you know that new wave type of [ __ ] is
like wave type of [ __ ] and and then I
just went just like you know it feels a
little too far I feel just like yeah nah
yeah now we're it's alright like now
we're happy Christians it's kind of cool
that you're open with it cuz like I said
man there's a lot of people who will be
in your position and they'll give you
advice on what you shouldn't have done
and chastise you when they're the ones
doing it themselves you know and those
people are odd to me it's like how do
you how do you live with yourself man
like nah how do you sit there it's like
it's like Cosby right
what is he how did he go up look at
other human beings and their comics and
say how dare you curse how dare you talk
about these topics you should you are
above this and the fact that you carry
yourselves like this you and the like
hehe was chastising [ __ ] Eddie Murphy
he almost wrecked his career and a lot
of comedians coming up yeah he was
drugging women and raping them on the
other side what kind of [ __ ]
psychopath
yeah yeah right but look I'm saying like
the honesty is great too because I'm
telling you man like you would be
surprised specifically in this industry
people out there how having a side chick
there's a reason why that term is so
popular and why people [ __ ] with it a
lot why that comes up in music a lot is
because it's a fact it happens all the
time yeah people are even okay with it
in Korean
your bro in like the business culture
these guys travel so much they step out
on the women all the [ __ ] time like
it's almost common it's almost odd that
you're not doing that and these ladies
who are at home I think I heard they're
like they like they go to like brothels
all the [ __ ] time and these women
they know about it but they there
they're there with a rich guy so they'll
take daddy's money and then they'll go
[ __ ] around with guys and so it's just
this weird weird situation as I'm saying
like understand what you're getting into
when you go into a monogamous
relationship because it's not just don't
think about it as oh this is something
that we have as humans have to do it's
not something that you have to do it's a
choice you have a choice to stay
committed to somebody if that's
something that you don't vibe with and
you just like living moment to moment to
moment with new people then definitely
being together with one person for the
rest of your life isn't something that
you want mm-hmm I like it because like I
said I like that somebody knows
everything about me they can help me
they can support me when I need it the
most and that's something that I can't
trade off mm-hmm good I think about an
old age when I'm in old age I want that
person next to me yeah it's fun right
now when I'm young when I when I when I
can do and I had the energy to what
happens when I'm 60 or 70 years old and
I just want to chill and just be with
somebody that understands me yeah I
don't have that there it's gonna be kind
of lonely yeah and that's really
important man cuz like like I said like
this like whatever whatever I like
growing up like that's that's what I've
told says we're just gonna keep this
honest train going yeah yeah like
growing up like in middle school and
even going to the high school like I was
a late bloomer
all my homies like they their [ __ ]
balls dropped hella early and they're
and they're got beards already and all
this [ __ ] nothing there and they're
actually like they're having sex and so
I'm out here like lying you know I mean
I'm sitting here like little shrimp dick
but I'm saying y'all don't want this big
dick my dick size and just not having
sex but I would be like yeah I'd be
[ __ ] yourself they're like but I just
I wasn't though and I was always like
fascinated like damn hot or whatever see
feel like yeah yeah and so when I lost
my virginity I lost it when I was in
ninth grade to a senior and she was like
one of the
the dancers of the sports like the drill
team would I am and so she's got a young
dick yeah bro and I feel like I was like
ha of course yeah I love I love more due
to a senior like [ __ ] y'all you know I
mean if [ __ ] bro something off from then
on I was like I feel like I had to catch
up yeah like everybody had their numbers
and I'm sitting here like alright I just
got one but alright bit so I just yeah
I'm I'm [ __ ] you know Mia and that's
how I like and I've always had like a
weird like insecurities and [ __ ] like
that where people would be like what but
I had a plastic surgery when I was two
on my lip that's why I had this little
scar right here because I didn't it's
not necessarily cleft lip but I was born
premature and like my lip that didn't
finish for me yeah everywhere so I got
pipe surgery but I always at a young age
I knew I was ugly which that I don't I
don't know I don't know if kids are
supposed to know that I don't think so
man I just found I was luckily yesterday
so I knew like I'm looking around like
I'm ugly like I don't I don't look like
everybody else I look I I was in my own
little thing you know I mean so that was
another thing of like [ __ ] I was like
alright I probably don't look good but
I'm gonna get you to laugh and be funny
and we're gonna [ __ ] yeah so that was
like my validation yeah I mean so
fast-forward to like now we're also
another version of that you know what I
mean we're all no I'm just like I use
that as a validation of like I'm good
enough yeah you know me oh I'm great
enough oh I'm this I'm this great
entertainer performing oh I was I was I
was so funny that I got late tonight
yeah you know what I mean so so and
again this isn't I'm not trying to
justify anything this is just it's just
you thinking of it's a thought process
of this understand oh yeah yeah yeah so
so that's how that's how I'm taking two
dads like that's why what we Makayla was
saying she was like if you already know
that you to [ __ ] when you get offstage
you're not gonna go why I gotta get laid
I'm just gonna be like this is what it
is
yeah I'm the [ __ ] I'm funny yeah that's
what we were talking about it on the
other podcast where we talked about
these earlier things that happen when
you're younger that you don't know that
affects you as an adult right so when we
were talking about a lot of the younger
women that I know
who realized later on that they were
sexually assaulted when they were
younger you know even for you your first
time USX was a girl that was four years
old than you yeah you don't know what
that does to you mentally right until
you're older right and so even for these
young girls they start to realize
they're like oh [ __ ]
maybe that guy did touch me
inappropriately maybe that's why I see
physical interaction as something
there's like for example I dated this
one girl who the only way that she felt
a relationship satisfaction is if we
were [ __ ] that's it didn't matter if
I did nice things for her doesn't matter
if I treated her right doesn't matter if
I said great things to her if we weren't
having sex like consistently yeah it
wasn't she didn't feel validated which
was such an odd thing like for me yeah
like I have sex but I'm not as hyper
sexual as my other guy friends growing
up it wasn't something that was
constantly on my mind 24/7 that's like
it was but I had better control my
impulses
right also because it wasn't as readily
available for me but for example for her
she at the time when I was in Sacramento
I was hitting up comedy clubs all the
time I was having this huge like turmoil
within my family because I decided to do
stand-up parents want to talk to me I
was working [ __ ] like three jobs and
I was attending college I was [ __ ]
busy you know yeah and so we wouldn't we
wouldn't have sex as much yeah and then
she just felt like I didn't care about
her I'm like no why why do you connect
sex so much with this [ __ ] with you like
we spend time with each other and I'm
exhausted yo like I was in school all
day I did my job I hit this [ __ ]
comedy club at night
it's [ __ ] 1:00 a.m. I'm not trying to
[ __ ] I'm exhausted
yeah I can't even get it up even if I
wanted to I'm [ __ ] tired yeah but for
her she only equated sex with a lot of
the stuff that she had and then we kind
of dive deep into it later on and you
know sir dive deep into it yeah you know
I mean we started we started [ __ ] no
but you know she she talked about it
just I don't know how it got to this
conversation but she talked about like
how she was actually sexually assault
and when she was younger and all this
other stuff and then just her whole life
she had sex really early on and she only
equated attraction with sex I'm not sure
if that had anything to do with it but
that seems to be the reoccurring theme
I think there's this weird relationship
with sex we can kind of get [ __ ] up as
a kid yeah and that's your interaction
with sexuality this really weird
situation yeah I mean I'm I want to get
a psychiatrist to talk about it but this
is kind of what I'm from what I've read
and how I've experienced it with people
and a lot of people who had this trauma
they have a weird relationship with sex
and that was her case too and in yours
it might not be that extreme but it was
your thing of yo I feel validated as a
human being because I don't have these
normal qualities that allow me to get
[ __ ] cuz all these guys when were
younger that's what they talk about do i
yo man I was [ __ ] this [ __ ] cuz I was
right there with you yeah I said I
didn't lie about it I was just more like
I'm not getting [ __ ] and it was kind of
obvious yeah good I remember when my
homie Rene his dad Filipino people our
section was [ __ ] man okay I Filipino
people like they even have something
called the barrel man which is like a
fertility goddess is dude in a barrel
Filipino just sounds like Philip on you
pull down the barrel and a dick comes
out like that's like like a fertility
god I'm not sure if it's a joke or if
it's real but that's what the barrel man
is okay and so I remember cuz I wouldn't
bring girls back to his house where I
wouldn't talk about my sexual conquests
I remember dad came up to me goes they
bid how come you don't like booze booze
huh you don't like booze booze that's
like no I like [ __ ] I just you know and
that's weird can you stop doing that no
please please don't kiss it yeah all
right man but even his dad would clown
on me about that [ __ ] right I just
didn't know mm-hmm but I later found out
too even for him like he would equate
like being a man with sex and so
everybody would talk about the [ __ ]
that they would and they would talk
about it like they had it all the time
yeah lo and behold when I actually saw
it in action you know he's not getting
[ __ ] all the time he just goes out gets
shot down four thousand times that grabs
any girl that'll touch him mmm you know
but when he tells the story it's yo I
went up to this chick and I just said my
shin non nabbed and I [ __ ] her it's
like nah you didn't talk about the 400
times you got rejected
Yeah right right they want to embellish
these stories they want to be the guy oh
my gosh I talk about the whole time
we're all talking about cousin about
that hike where he told me a story but
uh one of one of these guys who he's a
he's a influencer and a friend came over
to the house and he saw that there were
a women walking around with the with
just topless right yeah walk around the
house and then so I that story came back
to me and I was like okay how many times
does that happen yeah ever yeah unless
you're [ __ ] Hugh Hefner Yeah right
right so you know okay if that happened
you that's what you walked into saw okay
cool
but he's also what is it a roommate of
like six people or is it was it were
they shooting something or they just so
happened they just they were [ __ ] and
they walked out and they didn't know you
somebody was there so they went back
into the room because it was like oh
[ __ ] like you know they thought they
were home alone you don't know the
[ __ ] story but no the story's gonna
be in bells - where's I bro this dude
get mad [ __ ] and he's there top list
they've got to go because he's go he's
he has [ __ ] there every single day
and it's like nah bro really you know I
mean the funny thing is I even started
to figure out now it's like you know if
I look at a finance woman like she got a
fat ass or whatever whatnot I'm like
damn that's nice look but I realized
that I've kind of grown out of that
stage it was when I was in Hawaii
recently and there's a girl she was
swimming mm-hmm and we were in this
place called electric electric beach go
out it kind of has like strong waves
well when she was going out there to go
scuba diving her top kind of came off at
her titty fell out right and the only
thing I could think of wasn't like oh
that's a nice titty I was like there are
children in this water
I was see looking there I was looking at
her titty and I just came up to I was
like my first initiative my initial
thought wasn't that's a nice today it
was man there are children here yeah I
mean my deal was like it was a nice
titty but yeah like the initial reaction
wasn't for me to keep it there so I
could stare at it longer it was and I
had goggles while she would have never
known I was just no oh yeah but I was
like oh I'm in a different stage in my
life where I could appreciate the boob
what I can think of the bigger picture
yeah children the water yeah ladies you
don't want these kids to be traumatized
then they grow up later in fact
for some reason I only get horny when
I'm in the other [ __ ] yeah don't know
why and it just takes one titty I don't
need to see to it for some reason every
time I [ __ ] my grout that cover but you
just went in it I gotta grab it one tit
block it with my other eye wink yeah and
I gotta [ __ ] her that way I got a to go
back in time to the one time there at
the beach just floating around on the
water
yeah that's great that story's [ __ ]
it's a man yeah bro you have a very
special person that you're with it she
she really takes the time to you're
super bro and and it it makes me those
are those are things that I have to
always like remember cuz when she annoys
the [ __ ] out of me I had to be like this
girl's a solid girl oh for sure like you
know what I mean like yes because we
know each other like that's like let's
just get that out the way like we know
each other like just with whatever like
my humor is different or her humor is
different or she has this thing which of
like she's like why don't you ever laugh
at like my jokes and I'm like babe you
know I'm around comedy all day every day
or I'm thinking about comedy or I'm
always thinking about bits and was it
like and even when I watch I hate like
when I watch stand-up specials now like
I rarely laugh not that not that is not
funny
are you gotten to that point on yeah I'm
just not laughing I'm to the point where
I'm appreciating it now I'm like all
this guy's good yeah like I just watched
the the the special that just came out
the Sunday the Great Depression
on HBO Gary Gulman which is it's so good
like me my girl turned to her I was like
oh he's killing me right now
yeah you know of course yeah I've had
times where I laugh what I'm saying like
it was it's been a long time where I've
actually like been leaning over cracking
up laughing because now because I'm in
I'm in it I can appreciate it more of
like oh my god what a well-written joke
yeah you know to me yeah so so that's
why I tell her I have to explain that to
her cuz she's like whatever I'm funny
you know I'm just like babe yes
I told like you are funny do you not
realize when we're around people you
have people laughing all the time
guys you're funny you're gonna figure
silly you're a great person you have
great energy
I just I'm around at all times where I
was like put it this way you don't laugh
everything I say yeah or when I say
something done you're like uh whatever
you don't mean but if somebody was in
the car they'd be cracking up it's like
they'll you know whatever but it's just
you're used to it that's all it is
you know you kind of get desensitized to
a lot of stuff that's why for me when I
when people are like I think when I when
I talk about stand-up comedy and I go oh
this person is good but they don't see
me laughing just like in your case they
call you bring a hater say nah bro I'm
around funny people all the time so it
feels different now there's only a few
comics where I watched now where you see
me dying laughing like Chappelle
Chappelle's one of those people where I
look [ __ ] and I start cracking the [ __ ]
up right because he's so different and
it sounds like you're home he's talking
to you he has a way of lulling you into
his setups I don't know how he [ __ ]
does it yeah and I wish I could be on
that level but he's so [ __ ] good at it
there was the first special that was on
Netflix of Tom Segura okay that [ __ ]
happens good dying laughing right and I
was like up he's now one of my top five
yeah and then I saw this stupid-ass Stan
especially by area Peters called the
comedy blueprint okay that [ __ ] had me
[ __ ] me in Khalif dude we were rolling
laughing because it was so [ __ ] dumb
yeah I have heard a lot of bad stuff
about him and whatever that [ __ ] is and
I've had so whatever unfavorable
interactions with him as well okay that
still doesn't mean he ain't funny though
I can't take that away from him yeah you
know you might be a [ __ ] dick but me
ain't funny dude yeah
you know and they know that ya know that
they know they this is the way I am this
is what this is how I handle things is
how I like my green room or this is how
I like my line up when I have my
features and my openers hey whatever bro
it's so interesting cuz I listen to a
couple of it I wanted to bring him on
this podcast so he could talk about it
because I'm kind of curious about a
comic who says it's everybody else and
it's not my problem right and I that's
that's like Aries Spears is attitude
from the interviews that I've seen one
of those I'm not an [ __ ] I'm just not
smiling all the time but then the few
interactions I had with him on this
phone you know how he how he conducts
himself it's like I could see why people
think you're a [ __ ] dick though you
know it's not everybody else yeah there
you have to understand there's a certain
level of personal responsibility where
how you come off to somebody probably is
because you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it's not because everybody's
misunderstanding you then that means
that the billion of Billy
people in the world is dumb and you're
the only smart person now you're
probably a [ __ ] dick yeah and you
don't know that and you just think that
you're being yourself because maybe
you're that part of your personality
you're just socially awkward
yeah man there's a very fine line
because that's that's the thing when I
hate when people say oh I'm a realist
or I'm just keeping it real yeah you
know it's a very fine line because like
are you just being real are you just
being a dick
yeah you know for reals like are you
really just being a [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz
that's the thing like I mean that's what
my podcast it's keeping it true which is
the same [ __ ] that's but in Houston
trill is like you know that the highest
level of yeah real you know I mean so
you keeping it I'm keeping it 100 or
keeping it real it's like okay how
honest you can't you can actually be
very honest with somebody and still be
nice yeah period 100 you don't have to
you don't have to you know give these
you know negative opinions that are
really just your opinion yeah and you
should actually state that when you're
telling somebody that this in my opinion
instead of saying no you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it's like am i or you
actually because because they say I'm
just being real with you or just be a
real you're being a [ __ ] right now yeah
it's like no that's not you're not
keeping it real you can't being an
[ __ ] yeah you know I'm saying
so yeah I mean even moments where I am
an [ __ ] is I know I'm a [ __ ] ass
yeah you know I'm like okay but it's cuz
I don't like you that's why yeah for
example I had a somebody says something
me that really irritated me because he's
kind of a human being where he's very
judgmental about what other people do
without being judgmental to himself I
think that you can be an opinionated
judgmental person as long as you do that
to yourself as well mmm-hmm instead of
thinking you're always the [ __ ] hmm you
know so this guy has a has a habit of
critiquing other people a lot without
with never critiquing himself he might
do it internally but with the way it
comes off he comes off as a dick or he
tries to take everybody else's success
as the reason why you're successful is
because of me so you try to pull that
[ __ ] on me when we were hanging out and
he goes oh he goes I see that
relationship advice I gave you man
that's why you know you're you're
engaged now assume that advice to heart
and I'm gonna mouth like well how's your
divorce going it was like oh damn I was
like yeah bro yeah I felt that
that's funny how's your divorce code bro
yeah like trust me you weren't the
reason why I stayed together with this
girl you're the last person I would ask
advice for home I was like damn it's
kind of me David hey man Kevin trying to
[ __ ] with me again again because because
it's like the first time I've actually
been open about it on platforms but
Kevin knows about my situation yeah how
the [ __ ] would be right and like cuz
I'll pose I put my girl all the time
like all my story like I like messing
with her like really putting these
lovey-dovey stuff and so he'll he'll
respond in my story black but are you so
cheating on her okay they'll give me
like a [ __ ] dagger baby oh I had I
had one time I out of my story I was
like I had my girl I was like am i
obsessed with my girl because I have her
on my background on my computer on my
Apple watch I have around my phone and
that was like trying to just do a little
pull like in my obsessed did keV was
like did you have all that when you're
cheating and I was like that's okay I
said you cheat on diet that's all right
you know that's just love that's [ __ ]
hilarious yeah but that's cool because
you guys had that rapport and you guys
are comics too so it's different this
guy he's not a comic I just wanted to
hurt him bro you need to shut the [ __ ]
up
trying to take my mic all the [ __ ] that
I've learned from other people and say
it was because of you you proposed to
her yeah shut the [ __ ] up dude how's
your split relationship you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah about that yeah and and and so and
really people who genuinely help you for
you they don't ever bring that back up
yeah and I give them all the credit man
I mean yeah yeah and you know as a
person to give them that credit you know
you know the credit you got to give to
you know you have though you had those
lists of people to think about your
Oscar you know exactly I'm like how do
you know yeah yeah you just leave it
alone he's one of those dudes it's like
yo man I can't wait to go to the wedding
like that's funny yeah [ __ ] said you
were invited bro are you gonna be
working as a caterer or what's what's
going on well how are you sneaking in or
what stuff oh yeah no
and a half room oh [ __ ] man we are our
in bro yeah that's our yeah dude that
[ __ ] what's up what's up what's up boys
I don't get it in Brad knows what you
want
we got another podcast games coming
though damn we should have you know what
it is because you're really good at
talking to okay
most people all right continue yeah we
always say yeah keep talking but I think
cuz a lot of [ __ ] I forgot about that
[ __ ] but it's all good I always wonder I
kind of wanted to be like advice boy man
conversation was a liar bro for sure
yeah but man y'all gotta check out his
podcast guys one of the other pod care
they I kept it super ill on this podcast
so you can only imagine how how it trill
I keep it on keeping it true yeah man
and I always say to like if you guys are
listening to a lot of people who do
podcast the best people who do podcast
or comics man cuz it's just it's like no
holds bar man I love having comics on
here dude yeah just because like I
mentioned this before I've had people on
this here on here who said they had
great stores but they couldn't speak to
say the lines on them like we're not
uploading this ya know when's that going
up I was like in order for me to save
your career I'm not putting this up I
was like cuz you sucked yeah like it was
hard look at what we do and they go I
could do it yeah I still have hard times
of like trying to do these selfie videos
because your videos are really
impressive we like we need telling
people to like swipe up yeah and you're
kind you're promoting your the podcast
of what you just talked about I'm still
trying to get to that of like talking to
the camera hey what's going on guys
how's everybody do it
the Dro are did that [ __ ] really started
because I have a patreon and I started
vlogging again mmm - it's so hard like
the first videos I'm vlogging I'm like
this
that's that guys I'm in a restaurant you
really got to not give a [ __ ] about
personal space
yeah dad that - you have to you have to
get over the fact that everybody's gonna
look at you going oh my god on the
camera it's a I commend the people who
prank people at Walmart pranking like
these like I don't like it you're really
an [ __ ] and I really can't wait for
the person to prank me at Walmart I mean
what am i walking around waiting for
that [ __ ] prank to happen like yes
you go throw a towel um you're gonna
throw rice on me like what's gonna
happen yeah yeah me because I know it's
a [ __ ] prank and you're [ __ ] with
me yes I see people who vlog
I'm not knocking them right it's kind of
funny to me it's kind of socially
awkward but I do understand why they
have to because when you when you're
performing to a camera whether you're in
public or not people can sense when
you're uncomfortable so there was a
couple Clips I'm like hey guys I made
this my favorite I'd say so delicious
are you trying to be quiet I can't use
this I wouldn't watch this [ __ ] dude I
don't do that so now I when I do these
vlogs I try to go away from people a
little bit we're still in public but
it's not in anybody's personal space so
I'm trying to be mindful of them yeah
give a [ __ ] now if it's embarrassing for
me I do care if I'm disrupting somebody
else's days yeah and if you're with your
your crew sometimes you get they know
what you're doing so they're like I'm a
blogger real quick and that's cool but
yeah if your honor that's nothing I
can't I tell my girl my hey baby Cooper
go live for like 10 minutes yeah you
know I'm saying because if I go live bro
she knows mm-hmm like I'm just gonna be
completely committed to these 13 people
watching me strong 13 13 bro yeah life
is hard though cuz even if you have like
I have a half a million followers it's
only be like maybe 2,000 3,000 there
right so the percentage is small so I
think that makes sense yeah whenever I
got to 40k a Brad guy like 23 viewers
one time like I had once because you
know sometimes we need because when you
when you end your life it'll tell you oh
it was actually for you would be like it
was actually 70 thousand people watching
or whatever whatever then I was like mm
okay well yeah but yeah it'll show me 24
that are currently watching but then
whenever I ended they'll be like
actually you had a solid 32 yeah okay I
had a friend this is how much of an
[ __ ] I am sometimes and I keep saying
friend but I say he's an acquaintance
that I kind of like but I don't but this
[ __ ] he did an Instagram live
and mind you followers maybe 30 or 40
for I'm not knocking on that but that
just means that you have 30 or 40
followers we all know each other dude
mmm
so when you say hey guys this is what
I'm doing [ __ ] who you talking to my
[ __ ] are you talking to me Gary
treinen bang they are named just say our
names [ __ ] are you touch so he did this
Instagram live and this [ __ ] was
showing us his breakfast I got on signed
on and I was like stop embarrassing
yourself turn this [ __ ] off it says and
avi goes yo why you gonna do be like
that
I'm like bro you have like 30 or 45 we
know each other we're friends we're
forming two I was like are you trying to
be like an influencer if you are all
good just let me know just let me know
let me know I just thought it was funny
that you said hey guys we're all homies
we don't give up he just got an
Instagram so you guys like 35 yeah bro
what the hell like give me a heads up
yeah kind of clout I think like you
wanted to try try being an influencer I
know that yeah I just caught a cloud or
not on the money shot the [ __ ] off
you're embarrassing
[Laughter]
it's real yeah sure you feel me but
anyways guys you could catch us on
spotify podcasts iTunes whatever give us
that five star we're up every Thursday
and Sundays and this is what I love
about the podcast man it's just dope
conversation about random [ __ ] you know
it ends up being something amazing man
this is how smooth this hot no it went
so smooth you didn't introduce me this
at this episode oh I did oh [ __ ] that's
how smooth like we're just gonna go in
it so today we have a Christmas let's
put in right now so we have a crystal
sit here tell them what they can find
you again you can follow me on all
platforms my main thing platform is
popping is my ig at Christina Sousa CRI
STI you know salsa SOS a co we'll see
y'all next time peace